so yeah I can start so hello I'm Gango
fifth year PhD student in mechanical
engineering uh uh advised by Professor
mono Kennedy and today I want to share
the two different ways to improve the
robotic Dexter with Optical Tech sensor
which is called as Dance Tech
so we all imagine the robotic assistant
which is uh like uh recently showed from
the Tesla as uh like helping us like
such as foring t-sh t-shirt like this uh
which is even though it's tele operation
but uh to make this kind of assist to
lot happen around us I think the one of
the key bottom neck is the uh the Dexter
manipulation and researchers has been
solved this issue using the the external
Vision as you can see in the left uh by
which is the inhand orientation uh task
with the like just using a vision or
using a touch and vision at the same
time and uh it also showed that the uh
touch feedback actually has to do Inn
orientation or uh like make much better
than just using an external Vision but
what if the object is too small to
detect from the external Vision or the
object is too hard to detect from the
surface because of the cusion like for
example whether the object is gathered
at in the same place and it's in the
cluttered environment so uh I will share
two different case for solving this kind
of issue the first case is the where we
are uh thinking about the simple
scenario such as uh like grasping uh
screws or small object from the cled
environment such as you can see in the
right uh like and grasp and Orient and
classify those object from the clart
environment so the the external Vision
system may be insufficient for like
detecting those object because uh
there's too many occlusions and there
there are too many objects so you might
need to uh like train that model or
scene a lot to deal with those issue by
just using the external Visual and also
grasping the small object by uh like the
previous gripper is not possible so we
might need to use a small size gripper
or other kind of specialized gripper and
as well as the reorienting the small
object might need regress motion or any
other strategy by just doing instead of
doing just simple grasping motion here
so uh our study can efficiently solve
this issue by using our soft Tech
Optical Teti sensor which is called as
Dance T so there are few ways to deal
with this problem like for example
people are dealing with this problem by
just grasping it and then uh like
reorienting uh like UNC unconsciously
and then do classification by either
feeling the ttile feeling of the object
or by just seeing the object and I'm
trying to uh like mimic this kind of
strategy in our uh paper uh which can be
uh like pipeline as like this uh first
we detect the uh object uh where the
object is and then grasp and do inhand
orientation to do do better grasp or St
make stable grasp and then classify it
or which of the object that we grasp and
for the first process which is the
detect motion uh as you can see in the
left uh like let's say the screws or any
daily object are cluttered and it's
really hard to detect from the external
vision and for here we uh two deal with
the detect we haven't used any other
Vision algorithm to use this instead of
that we use the depth information out
the of the rear sense camera so this is
the scene that a robot will get so we
determine the highest point of the pile
uh as you can see in uh here and then
move the lobot into the right direction
to uh make the better or stable grasp
out of here uh this scene and then we
grasp the mo uh the object out of the
Clutter environment so this happens with
the gripper with the uh like this eight
degree of Freedom which has h two AIS Dy
four two AIS Dy Dy Motors and with the
fingertips at uh like using the optical
tactile sensor as a fingertip so this
fingertip uh is called the danch 2.0 we
which is one of the paper we made uh
publish is published last year uh so
this is the sensor so you can see it's
really soft and uh there is a camera
inside of the sensor so that uh the
camera can def uh determine or the
deformation of the sensor and estimate
the net range as the sh shape of the
deformed sens or deformed uh shape so by
uh yeah I really like skip this detail
of the sensor but the sensor estimates
the shape and the force through the this
kind of unit shape or encoder decoder
shape uh Network by the a lot of
training with the the data set so the
input is the image one single image and
it can uh determine the dense
reconstruction of the shape as well as
the net range of the sensor and using
this uh Teti sensor we are able to
achieve some compliant uh comp compliant
griper because the gel is too soft so we
can use the uh it allows the griper to
uh like adapt those uncertainties while
regress from the cluttered environment
so uh while it can actually do some kind
of uh distribute the force evenly while
grasping some uh like object or the
small object and it makes more uh stable
or the more successful grasp by just
using uh Le than just using a like lber
uh gripper or lber fingertip uh which is
used a lot of Lobo tips or fingertips so
and also since it's the ttile sensor we
can use those te tactile feedback
for like as a control input of our next
uh goal which is the interfinger
manipulation and then uh like this is
one of the um uh range that the Grier
can move and by using those uh like
various movement of the r uh various
range of movement we can achieve the
inhand interfinger orientation or in
hand orientation of the object where we
grasp the object so to do so to do this
we uh Define the state of the controller
by uh uh uh depending or according to
the feedback from the Teti sensor which
is the y-coordinate position of the
fingertip in the gripper frame which is
attached in the gripper or the angle of
the movement in this direction or this
direction inside of the of course in the
gripper frame and of course the input is
the four degree of freedom of the one
finger uh finger of this
gripper and uh we can solve the simple
Jacobian of of to do with this
controller and then use the uh inverse
Jacobian for uh deal with or to get the
right input of the controller uh and to
one of the important thing things to uh
deal with this controller to deal with
or get secure the stable grasp is the uh
finding the right objective of the
controller and we Define the uh
objective of this controller by
minimizing the data AB where with where
you can see in the this right uh image
uh which is the minimizing the angle
between the object and the middle line
which is the line between the center of
the this sensor and the other another
center of the uh one of the finger and
then by minimizing this uh data we can
actually make the we can always make the
uh like the small object is always in
between the center line of those two
finger and at the same time where uh we
also put the object objective on the
first state which is the y-coordinate of
the fingertip by maintain to maintain
the grass Bond object so it's constant
value and but def depends on the tech
feedback of the sensor so it can just
keep maintaining the Gras on object
while minimizing the data ab and as I
showed before since it has the four deg
Freedom like this uh it has additional
deg freedom to deal with the uh
stability inside of this Jacobian
controller and using this one we are
able to do the interfinger orientation
but uh we also tried many different uh
strategies such as RL or optimization uh
like using by try to learn the Dynamics
of the sensor but it actually didn't
work well because our first main issue
was the we used the ISAC gy but the ISAC
Jim uh didn't have the right U paralyzed
uh function or to deal with those
multiple issues uh M programming at the
uh at the same time with the deformable
object it does have the defal simulation
but uh it's not allowed to do some kind
of a par Computing and also even though
is possible those S sof deformable
simulation is not quite accurate enough
to uh deal with all of those uh like gel
simulation as you can see in here which
is uh really soft and it always attached
to the object while the gel has been de
deformed in like this way so it's almost
impossible to train the RL uh unless we
use the real data set and do the motion
all day long for our case or we try to
learn the Dynamics by uh like collecting
a data set of the grasping premium like
in this way and then uh like collect the
data set for the uh controller input uh
with the uh while reg grb some of the op
object but of course this is also too
noisy to use for the control and uh so
we concluded that uh inter we only just
simple jauan controller can deal with
those uh interfinger manipulation more
easily by just using a Teti feedback and
final step is done uh object
classification uh since we are using
this Tech sensor which uh where which
has the camera inside of the sensor so
we can estimate The Depths out of this
observed uh input and then we filtered
out using the DB scan to clusterize the
deformed or the detected screw like this
way and finally we can get three
different images as you can see here the
first one is the uh like the input from
the uh camera from of the dce tech 2.0
and the second one is the estimated
depth of the image and the final one is
the FI
or the calized uh uh information of the
sensor by doing so you are able to uh
like like Orient or reorient and crop
using the PCA and uh like train the data
set while collecting a data set from the
uh like this process the data set
collection has been done with while we
assuming those uh grasping happen with
those two gri or two fingertip
and we collected only 50 RGB and 50
corresponding death images per each
objec time while it has been fully
observed or are the partially observed
at and observed and we also try to
collect uh the many different situations
such as two scrolls are uh like observed
at the same time even though it's not uh
like handling all of the situation like
closing situation happens like that but
with tried to collect all all of the or
carbon all of the situation happen
during the uh classification and since
the data set is too small which is 50 uh
uh and 50/50 images per each label and
we try to pre-train the reset 18 for uh
classify this uh label and one of the
key thing I think is uh uh that works
well is we try to crop and reorient this
uh like
the image from the uh filtering or the
estimation of the Dance Tech uh we try
to uh like lift up some of the burden of
the network by reorienting or cropping
it by using the segmentation uh to uh
like train the network as easy as
possible and by doing so we were able to
classif classify those uh like many
different type of screws fairly well as
well as as some of the daily object we
can see which is still small to like
deal with or do some in orientation with
the existing ARL or the other algorithm
that has been proposed these days so
this is for Pipeline and finally we are
able to achieve the more than 80% of the
successful gr or like successfully
classify the screw with the different
heads or the different size of the
length of the screws so this is one of
the demonstration result so the first
the robot hand detects where the p is
the highest power point and then move
the like gripper slightly into the
gripper point and then gr be like is
and whether it two screws are not classy
is been draing two screws or one screws
at the same time and then do some small
in orientation and then classify it in
this way and we do this we repeat this
demonstration more than
20 200 steps and like in this way it's
all the like 10 times faster than people
and you're able to classify those object
EAS from
the so this is one of the solution I
proposed for the
dealing with the small object but what
if the gripper or the fingertip is
needed for grasping tiny object from the
glass surface table or the desk which is
easily can be seen in the our daily life
so to deal with like to deal with this
problem we are doing like proposing many
as a human we are proposing many
different strategy like for example for
the coin we are using the fingernail and
or for the really small object such as
the hex n or the basil seed we are
trying to like attach the object to our
finger fingertip like by just tapping it
and then try to stick the object to our
finger and then grasp it and I think uh
those strategy is really useful for and
try to adapt those strategy into the our
fingertip but turns out there are tons
of problems for the existing robotic
hand or with gripers with existing
fingertip so like for example some
robotic hands are too rarge to grab such
small objects or like we need some kind
of specialized two finger rer to give it
those flat surface grassin where most
rppers are lack of the capability to
detect the te feedback out of the is
those griper input or why we grasping
something from the glass surface so to
do deal with those issue we also design
another like he sensor which is called
the T Tech Min so you can see is
successfully grasping a clip on the
right side which can deal with grasping
the MTI multiscale object from the FL
surface so the objective of uh this
study is trying to grasp and sensing the
barrier size of the small object
including the 1 mm size of the basic to
like th objects such as coins or the
clips and general object at the same
time from the flat
surface so to deal with those problem we
designed a new sensor or the new
fingertip by making it much smaller as
you can see in here uh which has the
similar uh design scheme but has the
fingernail in it so the price is less uh
like it's much cheaper than the previous
one uh and using the smaller size of the
camera module as well as the faster FP
FPS uh but the main difference from the
previous sensor is the uh like applying
the attachable or detachable fingernail
design so we can keep all like it's been
fixed with the screws like as you can
see in here and then we can change those
uh like fingertip material by the other
one and turns out that the the most
matter
uh from the fingernail is uh the co
friction coefficient between the Surface
and the fingernail itself so we can
choose various materials of uh the three
printer to uh make this fingernail and
then of course there's LED inside of the
sensor and we dispersing the LED lights
to make the small or make everything as
small as possible and we propos three
different strategy for uh using this
Dance Tech meing uh first one is Tech
grasping fingernail grasping and then
the finger TI grasping first the T
grasping is the grasping the
uh uh object with the using the surface
interaction forces such as the
electrostatic force or the bandar force
so it depends on the surface material or
the depends on the shape of the object
or the weight of the object as well as
the contact area between the gel and the
object so since the gel is clear enough
to make some kind of B Force as well as
the electr static Force so you can see
the like P like which is
two M2 scale M2 siid can be easily
picked up with just by tapping motion
which is sticking to the finger as I
first proposed in the human strategy so
by doing this we can achieve the T pring
strategy with this fingertip and the
fingernail grasping which is using the
fingernail to deal with like grasping
the thin object out of the FL surface so
there are two different strategy working
on like grasping by using the fingernail
the first one is the Walling contact so
while the gra fingernail cannot slide
beneath to the bottom at bottom edge of
the object or this kind of strategy
happens so this will contact has been
happens as you can see here so it's
making Ling contact while oppressing a
coin like in this way I show you
again or the other way much which is
much simpler than that is while the
radius of of the fingernail is smaller
than the radius of the object you can go
to go directly beneath to the object in
this
way so by using two different strategy
we can achieve like high grasping
success rate with the fingernail while
grasping like dime or really small size
of the object even in the FL surface
like this way U achieving uh more than
90% of the success
rate and the final strategy is using the
fingertip which is the noral grasing
with using the two finger ke so we uh to
like evaluate our sensor we make the
detection pipeline by uh by using the te
sensor input or the camera input inside
of the sensor like we can achieve like
determine whether is pressed
or like it has been getting
the object correctly by uh like pressing
it again or checking or even detecting a
scraping motion or when we try
to uh scrape it out like in
this so like we finally evaluate our
sensor with using multiple objects like
such as bases or the m1.6 knot or M2
knots or paper clip or like B battery or
the really small size of such as that Di
and as well as the
bearing so I think the main take away
from uh like this presentation is uh
that sub te sensor can grasp classify
and or reorient do reorientation test
from the CL environment L than just
doing using some like complicated
algorithm by just achieving upgraded on
the hardware as well as we can also uh
regress really thin or small object by
using the surface interaction force or
the fingernail design on the loal T
sensor
thank
you um was really curious about because
you mentioned picking up tiny objects
from a flat surface or like from a
clutter surface but it's more like
laying down like this way for the screws
but if you're like picking up for
example a paper clip along its like
Direction where it's very thin like it's
like almost stepping out of the surface
will your camera be able to like
actually catch what exactly the shape is
because you need to find the center of
Mass to like yeah exactly so that's the
reason I like assumed the FL environment
and that's like one of the like one of
the it's not some kind of generalized
like environment but it's always
assuming the CL environment we since so
that the there is those quter of a tire
of the object can um easily move or like
working as a rid so that they can easily
change while regress like and just uh
keep changing the environment at the
same time so that's the one of the uh
way to solve those issue with the sof
processor and I think most people are
focusing on not changing the environment
but U making really like preserving
environment as much as possible and then
try to grasp it by like finding the
right grasp Prim before we Gras
something but instead of that is we
don't have to worry about those kind of
like complicated algorithm or process
but just grasp it because
it's is some time history of the the
image
useful yeah I will say uh the time
history of the image is really useful
for both uh sensor like for the uh D
Tech Mei uh we can see like how the
impact happens while we try to grb
something or like at that moment so we
can use that impact or if we have the
enough the frame late then we can use
that imp impact or the history for
achieving the other kind of the uh
algorithm or like contact information
how would you expect to use the history
information how would you incorporate
that's really great question so I'm
thinking uh about using those uh uh
information to deal with the measuring
the estimating the force of the sensor
itself uh like estimate the detected
force uh by
uh like since it's just impact so impact
can be achieved from uh it's really uh
some kind of enemy of the controller
like for I think so I I think we can
achieve those vibration state or can be
handled with this kind of like I was
thinking something simpler which is that
like when you Gras something I mean you
have not just the current frame but you
have previous place oh right yeah um and
it's the same object yeah right but the
condition of also but which means you
have more information yeah also it's
elastic yeah yeah I think that's really
great idea because uh since we can we
still need to keep uh make a contact
while we doing some kind of those like
complicated motion so those historical
uh input is really important for need
those
I guess just out of curios so you're
just using one single camera for
detecting the object right yeah one SLE
in that case um is there a way for you
to like estimate the distance between
your operator and the object so right
now uh you mean the first paper uh I
mean just like you know this is on the
Des desktop but like how far are you
going down keep going until you're like
getting a sensor feedback yeah so we are
using the best
camera
so uh you mentioned that you can also
Orient the tiny object how how you do
that
so those uh orientation can be done with
the simple Jai controller as I mentioned
before so in
here so uh like we are trying to since
our griper has four degree of freedom
and which is four level it has the four
level joint we can like move the Brier
like in this way or in this way or in
this way so by like setting of the state
of the controller with Y and this motion
or this motion of the state and uh
selecting the object as a minimizing the
data AB from the tech feedback we can do
the table bre uh are the reorientation
test